hay una alta probabilidad de que las
fuerzas israelíes hayan asesinado a
silvina bucle esa es una de las
conclusiones finales de la investigación
del tiroteo en el que la periodista
palestino estadounidense perdió la vida
agua que le fue asesinada el 11 de mayo
mientras cubría una operación militar
israelí en cisjordania ocupada el
informe asegura que debido al mal estado
de la bala no fue posible determinar si
ésta fue disparada o no con un rifle de
las fuerzas israelíes pero no se
descarta que haya sido así pues la
tragedia ocurrió en medio de un
intercambio de disparos indiscriminados
para la familia el informe oculta la
verdad y hacen un llamado al gobierno de
eeuu para que haga una investigación
independiente a su vez el gerente de al
yazira el medio en el que trabajaba
booklet asegura que las conclusiones son
sólo mentiras israel se ha negado a
asumir la responsabilidad del asesinato
de chirín nuestra familia no está
sorprendida por este resultado ya que es
obvio para cualquiera que los criminales
israelíes no pueden investigar sus
propios crímenes está claro que están
tratando de perpetuar la ambigüedad y el
engaño por un lado mientras que al mismo
tiempo se limpian de maldad al afirmar
que hubo intercambio de disparos
todo esto son mentiras porque todas las
cuentas y vídeos y testigos refutan sus
afirmaciones
en julio en un informe del departamento
de estado de eeuu se concluyó que los
disparos salieron desde posición israelí
pero más tarde el gobierno de joe biden
se retiró de la investigación y dejó el
análisis en manos de la nación judía